the New York City Police Department says
it is looking into allegations that a
detective and properly coached a witness
during the Harvey Weinstein
investigation Lucia Evans claims
Weinstein forced her to perform oral sex
on him in 2004 but new information
revealed yesterday cast doubt on Evans
story in response prosecutors abandoned
part of the sexual assault case against
Weinstein CBS this morning Saturday
co-host Michelle Miller sat down with
Evans attorney for an interview you'll
see only on CBS this morning Michelle
good morning good morning
Evans was among the first women to
publicly accuse Harvey Weinstein of
sexual assault in The New Yorker last
fall in May she became one of three
women to form the foundation of the
criminal case against him but in a
stunning reversal now five months later
Evans attorney says the district
attorney has abandoned her client why
now I Ungava Lucia Evans attorney Carrie
Goldberg says she has no doubt that when
Evans was an aspiring actress in 2004
Weinstein forced her to perform oral sex
on him at his Manhattan office
she's been steadfast for the last 15
years that she was forcibly sexually
assaulted by Harvey Weinstein there is
no writing in existence that refutes
that but in a letter to the defense
unsealed on Thursday Manhattan
prosecutors disclosed that a friend of
Evans told an NYPD detective in February
that Evans agreed to perform oral sex on
Weinstein in exchange for the promise of
an acting job the detective acknowledges
he failed to inform the District
Attorney's Office of important details
of the interview but Goldberg says Evans
friend changed her story maybe I should
ask this was it your client that
introduced this friend in the first
place
it was my client that introduced this
third party as as a witness but you have
to understand that my clients version of
events was corroborated by this woman
and and then it wasn't until she was
questioned with her father and lawyer on
the phone that suddenly there was there
was an about-face we have to look at
motives here this was 15 years ago for
this woman also after a judge dismissed
the charge Thursday
Harvey Weinstein emerged from the
Manhattan courthouse with his attorney
Ben Bronfman sexual assault is a serious
crime but falsely accusing someone of
sexual assault is also a very serious
crime
Goldberg pins the blame on the district
attorney I really believe that the DA
made mistakes in their failure to
investigate evidence and witnesses
properly I mean this has nothing to do
with with Lucia's claims the Manhattan
assistant DA says she remains confident
in the overall case against Weinstein
The New Yorker stands by its reporting
Weinstein has pleaded not guilty to the
sex crimes he's been charged with and
has denied all allegations of sexual
abuse he still faces five remaining
counts that his attorney is also seeking
to have dismissed now I talked to Ricky
Kleeman last night and I asked her I
said did the DA drop this case this one
count
to avoid the mark fuhrman effect in a
sense you know he was discredited by on
the stand in the OJ Simpson case
so she said most definitely their hands
were tied they needed to get rid of this
one count
in order to keep the other allegations
clean ordered from them absolutely okay
Michelle thanks so much thank you